haben sie eigentlich an den eindruck
dass wirklich wofür steht rüeger im
versus 14
der bamberger hat es die zeit bis nach
der sendung nach der sendung die separat
nichts muss dieses team zu schaffen sein
gehe ich habe einen tipp für die
zuschauer
das sei mit den 1000 st er hat dann aber
flott herr wolf lotter wieder flott zu
sehen ist und früher war sie sowieso wie
ein koffer stehen glas ist so wie es ist
weniger eine chance aus dem hut die
sowieso morgen das wird mir diese chance
entwickeln ist das ist ganz lustig so
dass wirklich schwere hirnschäden mäuse
so die höchsten muss nachweisen dass mit
dem hund nicht so hier
zu groß für bier das mir am liebsten ist
der bamberger was für besen am liebsten
[Gelächter]
zu kriegen
den gag kunst in den sendungen über ja
ich denke darüber nach es ist so nett
uns war der mann mit einer tv sendung
unser hausmeister baumberger
[Applaus]